[Musique]
Paris ville musée avec ses édifices
patrimoniaux et ses immeubles
haussmanniens mais dans la dernière
décennie de plus en plus de gratte-ciel
ont modifié ce paysage comme ici dans le
13e arrondissement ou une société
québécoise a construit ces deux grands
tours pourquoi les tours à cet
endroit-là parce qu'en fait c'est un
endroit qui est très bien desservi et
faire de la densité et de la grande
hauteur sur les zones très bien des
services ça a beaucoup de sens
entièrement mental et aussi beaucoup de
sens sur le Plan d'Urbanisme de Paris
les tours du haut risque toutefois
d'être parmi les dernières de la
capitale Paris veut interdire les
gratte-ciels sur son territoire
[Musique]
les Parisiens vont être contents que ce
soit la fin des tours à Paris c'était
lui écologiste habilité pour cette
interdiction plus qu'une préoccupation
esthétique elle voit dans la
construction de tours un non-sens
écologique ou pour c'est tout le
contraire de la modération d'une
consommation énergétique il y a toute
cette consommation de matériaux de
ressources du monde entier pour
construire ça et pour mettre des bureaux
dont on n'a pas besoin
résultat de ces pressions le prochain
Plan d'Urbanisme de Paris doit fixer la
hauteur maximale des bâtiments à 37
mètres soit environ une dizaine d'étages
[Musique]
oui bien sûr c'est une victoire
un soulagement pour plusieurs livrets
qui souhaitent une densification moins
agressive et moins verticale vous en
réfléchi un petit peu et on se rend
compte que c'est pas fait du tout pour
c'est pas fait du tout pour loger les
gens on se rend compte que sans surtout
des
espèces d'épave thermique c'est
complètement anti écologique ça coûte
cher
à Montréal c'est l'inverse les tours
semblent pousser plus vite que jamais
trop vite selon cette expert qui croit
que la métropole québécoise devrait
s'inspirer de Paris
si on disait qu'à Montréal les dents ces
banlieues proches et même plus
lointaines en se limita 37 mètres comme
à Paris je pense que ça serait pas une
catastrophe si on voit que les grandes
tours résidentielles qui consomment
énormément de béton qui concerne
énormément d'énergie pour leur
construction et pour leur fonctionnement
ont un impact environnemental plus lourd
que des bâtiments de taille plus moyenne
ben il faut il faut en tenir compte nous
sommes les premiers à dire non autour
Corinne Fougeron espère aussi que
d'autres villes suivront l'exemple
parisien et réaliseront que la folie des
grandeurs et de moins en moins à la
hauteur du défi climatique ici
Radio-Canada Paris